tonight on the show we've got one of the
stars of Game of Thrones will I find out
if Daenerys Targaryen and marches with
the unsullied on King's Landing will
Stannis Barbara Theon
Baelish at winter is this the one with
Gollum in it I don't know I just get for
free
Cersei
ill in pain
the mountain
Barrett dondarian
source of Mir
the red woman
Tom Hanks
actually Joshua
[Applause]
yay
Pandora is so huge now arguably it now
is the most successful TV show in the
world it's the most legally downloaded
show
the highest viewing figures ever for a
HBO show is it 14 Emmys so Rebel are you
a big fan of Game of Thrones
to admit I'd never seen Game of Thrones
so
no
do not have a [__] TV
congratulations on the finale which
rocks the world it drove people crazy
yes and you must have read that script
with some trepidation I did yes
yeah yeah rap gift wrap gift right
Game of Thrones
um so it's all done we're talking about
now yeah which must be for you such a
relief it is nice it is nice I've been
keeping in these spoilers for so many
years and I can finally say goodbye to
you yeah yeah because that video kind of
went viral of Jessica trying to guess
what was going to happen in the last
episode how much did you get how much
did you get right not very much Queen of
the North you said oh I haven't seen any
of it so
you haven't seen any of the series I
haven't seen any of the series
the time you get to the last again it's
gonna take you seven years I know but I
I like to wait for these things to end
and then you can binge it yeah I don't
like to wait for the next season no it's
too long otherwise you're waiting 10
years yeah it's been seven years I know
but now uh Jessica's not the only big
fan because uh this now is this your
husband who's this post meeting you or
was this before meeting you uh when
this is post meeting me I actually
picked out the costume for him and I did
his hair yeah I thought that's how he
wooed you yeah
send pics
doesn't he look gorgeous it does was it
Halloween at least it was Halloween oh
okay that's something yes but here's the
thing you were in that show since you
were 13 13. and I mean
obviously you you know and now I'm 15.
it's incredible but you know but you get
that you get you know we all get one
childhood and that was yours was on that
show and looking back on it now is there
any sense of you know you feel like you
missed out do you bump into kids from
school and kind of think oh I wish I'd
or are you just are you pleased it was
Game of Thrones well I wish I'd had that
University experience definitely I wish
I'd kind of you know been able to go out
and drink a lot and like throw up in the
middle of a club and not get pictured
doing it so now I have to be a little
more careful I have to do it in the
toilet
taking the picture
obviously Game of Thrones it's such a
huge fighty show but you didn't really
get to do any of the fighting no early
on uh when they realized
um that he shouldn't fight they
attempted to make me into one of those
fighter guys and uh so I was out in the
battle with an ax and uh shot the guy's
leg off
um the gentleman whose leg dropped off
was God bless him a an amputee so that
he was about probably about 70 years old
so the one man I did Kill early on in
the show was about a 70 year old amputee
so that's not very heroic
in my opinion that's not a great day at
work no not shooting your father spoiler
alert on the toilet again not very
heroic and somehow people still like the
character so
how lovely having that paycheck for what
I mean 10 years but was it
was it nice yeah
but was it was it anyway a relief when
it finally came to an end
yeah
yes I mean it's time to move on as hard
as it is that's the tricky thing about I
mean that's what we do for that we go
off for a couple months and we have
great friendships and then you don't see
each other again and that one was a
family because we I lived in Ireland
basically and it wasn't just the show it
was the life I had children there
um my daughter had an Irish accent
affected Irish actor totally affected um
but truly we my feet were just in
Belfast the community up there is so
beautiful and yeah made so many good
friends Jason you you've only just got
to Britain yeah I've been here for
probably a week okay
okay I like it here
about yes yes I'm known for my
Shenanigans yes and because we spotted
you around London with your Widow from A
Game of Thrones yes uh Emilia Clarke she
posted this picture of the two of you oh
nice picture now when was it
was it oh that was like three days ago I
just actually flew over to Belfast uh I
got back from Belfast right now okay so
Bill in November why are you wearing a
vest
it's the first time I've ever wore a
turtleneck my mother's gonna be very
proud of me but I'm gonna be it's gonna
be close for peeling this off and
getting it getting there
[Applause]
but no but fans must go crazy when they
see the two of you together I go crazy
when I see her do they want you to start
talking in is it Dothraki Dothraki yeah
it's all nonsense but you do speak some
Dothraki I I I've been known to yeah say
a few things go on then
for the ladies okay
I love you but sorry
oh
[Applause]
yeah
and for the gentleman oh yes
[Applause]
yeah on the couch has had a memorable
encounter with nature Now Matt Smith uh
you were I believe we you were the lady
friend now were you in a garden or were
you in a field where were you oh
is it the WASP yes
well I was under a sort of Veranda it
was like a Moroccan rat this is a while
ago on my ad but I was under a sort of
veranda and we were
you know we were we were we were we were
we were yes
she was on top and I you know you get an
idea sorry sorry to be crass but anyway
to cut a very long and terrible stories
thank you Craig
um what happened was she it sort of
mid-thrust as it were
this is true it's it's terribly true I
was stung
I was stung on me goodness
so I sort of yelled out and she
obviously thought it was incredible
[Applause]
start hopping around and the Bloody wasp
would stop me on the knackers
Game of Thrones yes you do a lot of
horse acting exactly
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm an all right horse woman they taught
me to to ride a horse but we did have a
scene where it was um a very very farty
horse and it wouldn't go whatever the
technical term of making a horse go let
me take a little squeeze with them yeah
wouldn't with a kick it wouldn't go but
anyway but all the way up well Alfie and
I were doing our lines and it's a scene
where we get quite
or was it that scene yeah oh yeah yes
yeah yeah
and that was one of my audition scenes
which was quite interesting but no but
hang on so but I thought that the
audition scene was the other way around
yes it was the other way around so in
the actual scene it was
um Alfie
working away on me but in the audition
um my mother's watching working away
um
has your mother not watched Game of
Thrones
something she doesn't ask about
um everyone Tunes in and hears you
talking about Alfie working at well on
you it might be quite strange
I don't remember being in this again
but in the original scripts it was that
my character um it said Yara and my
character is worrying his [__]
yeah
did you leave the hop on
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah
that's some sort of bucket list Gemma
and then I said to Morgan
okay
hi baby hello
Jason
I have so many so much
Jason Jason boss it's like looking in
the mirror
no it's all good have a seat have a seat
hi hi hi darling
[Applause]
finally reunited with your wife yes it
was meant to be but we now discover you
know everybody uh you've met Regina as
well yes yes my wife
so many people we have six degrees
those are your boats in the DC Universe
yeah I know I I know yeah yeah
that's amazing is that a euphemism
really
happens
and of course you look alike is here as
well yeah yeah yeah this is this is
essentially what you would look like if
you were chopped off at the knees and
never went to the gym
could you take this as a warning
oh annoyed you'd be on Saturday you
stunt doubles here really
and Jason Emily you have seen each other
since the Game of Thrones
oh every time I come to England I'll
call Mike oh and in fact I just
remembered so because this goes out uh
we're taking this on a Thursday so this
goes out tomorrow night yes so will you
tomorrow night so when we we won't be
here we'll be at my party we'll be at
her party yeah
do you want to I'd love to come there we
are yeah so as long as Jesse can swap
clothes and I turn up first
[Applause]
oh there it is oh oh there you go Ross
is so happy
so here we go
[Applause]
thank you
oh I'm not sure if this fur is as wet as
this coat is but
it is awesome that's a bit there
but I'm all for it your Aquaman
[Applause]
that might be done for this cat food in
the pocket
you know but also your own mother
doesn't watch Game of Thrones does she
no she stopped after uh season one
episode I don't know what it was it was
when some guy's arm got ripped off his
body
good noise over there oh she rang me and
she said no it's too much I'm not doing
any more no and then like she decided to
pick it up again later on yeah but chose
just the wrong episode
which is when I was having my love scene
in a cave
second call going no darling
that's a very good noise love scene in a
cave
[Applause]
hello oh my God
oh my God
he looks more like you than you do
that's where you're here
that's nuts what's your name uh Matt no
[Applause]
wow now have you have you made yourself
looked like Matt Smith uh no I think I
Was Born This Way yeah there's a tragedy
isn't it yeah
where do you live Matt uh Bristol in
Bristol yes so close to Cardiff yes do
you have a question from outside yes I
do in the children's eclip that was
shown
um David Tennant wears The Fez I was
wondering if any more hats were involved
in the episode and did you get the Fez
on John Hurt
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]